what is happening there reject nation we
got ourselves finally finally the
trailer for the show that cost 4.8
billion dollars to put together roughly
lord of the rings amazon series trailer
hit that like button if you can guys i'm
only gonna watch this once so watch this
with the eyes of a hawk in the ears of a
fox oh
let's see what you did there jimly
i stand by potatoes second breakfast
[Music]
haven't you ever wondered
what else is out there
there's wonders in this world
[Music]
wow
[Music]
sweet
i know what i'm doing for my birthday
i don't know what's going on
but man do i have nipple children
i kept getting like the music the
visuals like that is that that looked
expensive just lead with gravitas that
was a very expensive trailer that was so
impactful and so much without like there
was not a lot of dial it was just
emotion it was just emoting at us you
could see where all that money's gone to
it's really taking advantage of that
budget early on like halfway through it
i was thinking you know there is
something kind of refreshing about
seeing the imagery here it has this like
cinematic scale to it but it still feels
like a television show if that makes
sense it also feels familiar but
different which is the goal always of of
rebooting or remastering right well i
think it does because of the fact that
peter jackson's not directing it and the
lord of the rings imagery is so iconic
and even like when you look at lord of
the rings and then the hobbits really
still feels like it's directed by the
same person sure you see this stuff here
and like this doesn't feel like it feels
like inspiration influenced but it
doesn't look like peter jackson's behind
the camera on it i like the fact that i
don't really know what's going on i
guess i guess the question is is like we
got to know really what's at stake we
got to know who their characters are
when you're already taking care of the
biggest stakes possible in your world
with the lord of the rings now it's
about getting us invested in these brand
new characters and seeing like what's
their perilous journey gonna be like are
their lives gonna be at stake to the
point we're gonna be concerned if they
live or die throughout it because you
know you can do as much world building
as you want but if you don't give a [ __ ]
about the characters then none of this
is really gonna matter i wanna get a
little bit more of a sense of that but
in terms of a first impression you're
like yep that looks expensive and it
looks like lord of the rings so we're
doing it and the music is great johnny
yeah i mean this was certainly a
dazzling first look i i'm sitting here
really kind of holding my breath because
i feel like this i'm wary of this
prospect because of what you just said
which is we've seen the kind of defining
story of the lord of the rings trilogy
and the age that this takes place in
ends with the vanquishing of sauron if
i'm remembering that correctly part of
me uh hopes that it doesn't fall into
the trap that i feel like you know
something like a harry potter has with
the grindelwald series where it's like
we gotta come up with a new thing to
kind of rival the stakes of having a
voldemort but that's not the same thing
granted there are tons and tons of
extended writings of jrr tolkien to draw
from uh and it definitely looks like
they've realized the world beautifully
now i just hope that they truly have
because in talking about the show some
of the you know creators and stuff have
said you know like we gotta do whatever
we want here that is exciting but also
makes me a little afraid because as
we've also seen with like game of
thrones when you run out of that
structured source material you can
sometimes end up having something that
looks beautiful and that is kind of
empty inside so really i just hope that
they have a great story because you
don't need me to tell you the production
values look incredible you know well
yeah i mean the things just like they
gave them all the money in the world to
make this and it's all writing off of
the title
like that's the craziness nothing else
no actors of no specific anything except
a title you're being unusually quiet i'm
a bit overwhelmed because i had been
only casually excited i like lord of the
rings but it was never the fandom that i
felt like i knew enough to commit to
it's one of those fandoms like star trek
and star wars where i'm like i love it
but that's a strong word because there
are people that love it so much they
blankety-blank like fill in here i
really enjoyed the trailer but i
definitely am excited to watch it as
something that i don't have a hundred
associations to my expectations are
coming from a consumer standpoint i
never get that feeling i get to actually
be like i'm not trying to fill in blanks
i'm not trying to easter egg i'm not
trying to look for things that reference
a panel from my childhood i get to
actually go like what are those moose
guys in the beginning
look at them go they look cool and like
it was really nice as a consumer to be
like this looks dope and i don't know
what's going on and i look forward to
that for the entire run well you see you
brought up an interesting point which is
that this show is supposed to take place
like thousands of years before the the
first movie we ever got right it looks
like there's a maybe they're going to
the battle at first there was one shot
there that seemed like you know the
opening battle the lord of the rings i
mean the real book readers and the real
people who know the movie so
yeah yeah fingers off and all that stuff
it looks like they might be going to
that but other than that moment what i
was actually surprised by with this
trailer was it didn't do the trick that
i thought they would do which is oh my
god they're back oh my god nostalgia
like they didn't do anything
like this whole thing would seem like i
don't know who these people are i don't
know what that is and the arrows like a
black elf that's about it that's about
the difference that you can get they
were smart by doing moments that were
like the bad ass moments like the arrow
shooting turn around blah blah the
action set pieces but having a slow pace
to build to those it was only a minute
but we had like slow slow slow build
slow slow slow build like it was
investing i know nothing it's still at
the same time though if it wasn't called
the rings of power lord of the rings i'd
be like this kind of still looks like
another fantasy show that i'm willing to
skip over well that's what i'm afraid of
they're reaching into lord of the rings
to fill there we need a game of thrones
type of void and to your point about
like you know not doing the thing i am
curious because again they've said like
oh yeah you know this opens the door we
can use familiar characters and
non-familiar characters and part of what
i am maybe a bit excited for is that you
might get more expansions on characters
that we saw mainly through flashbacks in
the original film because yeah you see
the battle that is supposed to end this
epic and this epic is supposed to see
the rise of the ring raids and you know
the forging of the 20 rings of power and
all that stuff so i mean you'll at least
get sauron and some other people he was
involved with but yeah i mean i doubt
you'll i would be very surprised if
beyond maybe elrond is that old or
something you would see anybody like i
know you'll see you'll see galadriel i
know they released it see that this
thing is like maybe that we did see some
characters and i'm like oh that's just a
different casting and i didn't know yeah
and that's what's gonna be interesting
for me is like the hobbit had orlando
bloom in them a ton more than i expected
and the whole time i kept being like is
this in the book or is that guy just
handsome
we can make up whatever we want so this
guy's been alive a little longer like it
is interesting because there's such a
lore they're such a fandom they're such
a strong association but not to this but
to stuff like this yeah because this is
brand new at the end of the day they put
a lot of money into something that isn't
technically a book it's just based on
books so i i don't know if they've ever
ratings yeah this is the first of its
kind thing i don't think that anyone's
ever invested this much money into a
thing that wasn't actually source
material directly associated with an ip
it's like an ip adjacent like it's like
a what-if
yeah it's further down the hobbit road
they took all that extra writing and
they supplemented the hobbit
let's go even further with that like
this is elevensies like we've had
breakfast
we'll see what this is
we'll find out together and i'm excited
because it looks gorgeous there are only
so many hours in the day and i love that
we live in an age of i've gotta pick my
battles with genre content but i don't
have time for even the stuff that i'm
invested in the source material of so i
hope there's enough of a draw in the
first few episodes and that's what's
hard is this is by definition a slower
burn because you don't want it to feel
rushed the beautiful thing about lord of
the rings is that it takes its time
homies walk a long way
it's kind of the thing yeah so you don't
want to rush like don't jump on that
eagle and fly to mordor don't you do it
like i want to take my time but if i
don't know these characters will i want
to hang out with them enough to be
invested to walk tomorrow more potatoes
though more potatoes man those are my
thoughts i i hope i'm invested in the
potato at all all right guys well are
you investing the potato leave your
thoughts down below are you excited for
this subscribe click that bell hit that
like button catch you guys soon
you